Oh my God, he will
not let it go.
You can tell he's Latin,
because Latin people are tenacious.
My name is Nick Barili,
and I'm traveling the country
to sit down with some of
the biggest Latinx artists
in places that have
meaning to them
and help tell their stories.
Hello, hello.
How are you doing?
This particular building
is the Chicano studies
It’s a pretty special
place for me.
We'll talk about their
journeys and careers
and explore issues of identity,
culture, discrimination
and representation.
I got scars in my head
from hitting that glass ceiling.
Trying to understand
your culture and your heritage
and the roots
that make you
the human being
that you are,
sharing it so that
others can understand it,
makes everybody stronger.
This is Seen.